2 мільйони 600 тисяч людей з інвалідністю,
за даними Комітету соціальної політики Верховної Ради,
отримують пенсії у розмірі від 1700 до 3000 гривень на місяць.
На ці гроші, вважає 67-ми-річний Віктор Олександрович
можна хіба що виживати.
Це не пенсія. Це зараз пенсія називається?
Люди мають самі про себе піклуватися,
самі мають заробляти гроші…
Віктор Олександрович хотів би від держави не стільки пенсію,
скільки допомогу з придбанням якісного протеза
та фаховий супровід звикання до нього.
Це дало б йому можливість згодом знайти собі більш-менш нормальну роботу.
Як стверджує депутатка від партії "Слуга народу" Галина Третьякова,
якість життя людей з інвалідністю в Україні може повністю змінитися.
Депутати готують масштабну реформу.
Насамперед вони хочуть ліквідувати МСЕК - медико-соціальні експертні комісії,
які є нині головними інстанціями, що визначають групу інвалідності,
від якої, власне, залежить розмір державної грошової допомоги.
Є МСЕК.
Якщо ми знаємо, що цей орган корумпований, що там купують інвалідність,
що має зробити держава?
Вона має змінити систему.
Ми задекларували в Конституції, що йдемо в ЄС,
то давайте зробимо європейську систему.
Європейська система - це запровадження МКФ -
Міжнародної класифікації функціонування,
обмежень життєдіяльності та здоров’я.
Замість трьох груп інвалідності - практики ще радянських часів,
з’являться 10 класифікацій ступенів втрати здоров’я.
МКФ - це класифікатор, який використовують в усіх розвинених країнах
лікарі, педагоги, спеціалісти з реабілітації та психологи.
Це підґрунтя для розвитку системи реабілітації, інклюзії,
для планування заходів соціального захисту, систем компенсації тощо.
На підставі цього висновку людині з інвалідністю
має надаватися комплексна допомога:
не просто призначати пенсію, а й запропонувати варіанти
поліпшення стану здоров’я людини або якості її життя.
От втрачені кінцівки. Сіла на візочок.
Візочком ок, обладнали.
Констатували 70% втрати функціоналу, дали візочок.
Але це не кінець для цієї людини
Людина хоче, можливо, стати на протези. Це важко і боляче
Що має робити держава?
Вона має надавати активні реабілітаційні послуги,
скеровані на те, щоб людину поставити на ноги, на протези.
Наразі чи не єдина реабілітаційна послуга від держави -
це надання безкоштовних путівок у санаторії, які не модернізувалися ще з часів СРСР.
Бюджетні гроші, які витрачаються на ці путівки,
депутатка пропонує скерувати на надання
комплексних реабілітаційних послуг для людей з інвалідністю.
Над цим проектом нині працює міністерство охорони здоров'я і мінсоцполітики.
46-ти річний юрист Національної асамблеї людей з інвалідністю
Олег Полозюк у візку з шостого класу - пірнув у ставок і травмував хребет.
Він уважно вивчив усі 250 сторінок МКФ.
Ідею переходу від радянської системи МСЕКів на нову європейську він вітає.
Але вважає, що спершу Україні слід серйозно підготуватися до такого переходу.
Ми знаємо, що "гладко было на бумаге, да забыли про овраги".
Ідея така, щоби призначення інвалідності відбувалося в автоматичному режимі.
Закладаються в програму вихідні дані
- і комп’ютер видає результат.
Але ж ми знаємо, що без людського фактору ніде не обходиться,
тому треба, щоб склалася практика.
Можливо, треба спочатку запровадити якийсь пілотний проект.
Комітет соціальної політики Верховної Ради вже розпочав
обговорення реформи з громадськими організаціями.
Обіцяють також продовжувати створення
інклюзивного громадського простору.
За словами Олега Полозюка, це єдина галузь,
в якій Україна за останні 20 років зробила більш-менш помітні кроки вперед.
Я спостерігаю це з 83-го року.
Якщо я провів 12 років на 7-му поверсі - просидів,
то зараз я вільно пересуваюся.
за цей час я навчався в школі 4-ри роки заочно,
потім заочно навчався в університеті.
Тобто я був чимось зайнятий.
А якщо людина доросла опиняється в чотирьох стінах, то там багато суїцидів.
Олег Полозюк отримує щомісяця 2300 гривень допомоги з інвалідності.
Але живе він на гроші, які заробляє як адвокат.
Він багато тренується, став майстром спорту з параолімпійського плавання.
Але знає, що такі можливості є далеко не в усіх.
Юрист Національної асамблеї людей з інвалідністю
не дуже вірить у те, що результати реформи будуть відчутні
вже через 5 років, як це обіцяють у Комітеті соціальної політики Верховної Ради.
Проте він переконаний, що Україні все одне від такої реформи нікуди не дітися,
адже в умовах війни на Донбасі людей з інвалідністю
в країні ставатиме дедалі більше.
Першочерговим і найбільш реальним кроком адвокат вважає створення
облаштованих робочих місць для людей з інвалідністю.
Як запевнили DW у Комітеті соціальної політики Верховної Ради,
відповідні зміни до законодавства, які зобов’яжуть роботодавців робити це,
планується запровадити вже наступного року.